it's time for roses and Rose day oh what
a nice
you guys what was more dramatic The Game
of Thrones Season Finale the release of
Taylor Swift's look what you made me do
video or Monday night's episode of
bachelor in paradise
I could barely take it that's what
tonight everybody I got a big gulp of
Rosie that's a big one there's a bigger
old cookie that's the whole bottle I'll
show you
I will proof it oh my shot so some
boring moments major drama
that's what you're gonna get in two
hours of television let's get to it
drink every time a boring game was
played jazmine like had Jack stone eaten
mystery things including some weird dead
stinky crap I can't it smells like fish
Amanda Stan suggested planks category
[Music]
hey they gotta fill the time you know
okay to catch everybody up again jasmine
is very intimate she's kind of
terrifying a little bit and then
newcomer
Kristen arrives and Kristen was a virgin
on Knicks season and I guess she's still
a virgin is paradise even paradise
without a virgin in it and drink every
time that Jazmin talks about being into
Matt you know what choking you also you
know what though props to Jasmine
because drink every time she looked good
in some kind of a head paraphernalia I
don't know what that white thing was
like a seashell headband or something
so Kristin comes into paradise and she
comes in strong like the white Walker
paradise
[Music]
she is ready to go on a date
Jasmine told me immediately Matt and I
are in a super serious relationship
that's been going on for two days
we're basically married I did think that
I wasn't necessarily and Kristen's like
mad you want to go out of day she's like
now you're really good-looking coming on
strong okay but you know what
Matt's coming right back he's like I
want to go on a date with you and then
Jasmine comes on strong with her
response you want good TV ABC I'm up
they give you good TV drink every time
someone comes on strong still a virgin
but that's all gonna change
they had that short filming schedule but
they were there to bring the drama and I
like it I felt like this episode finally
got us to a place of drama that we've
been looking to be without the scandal
being involved but of course on Tuesday
night's episode were gonna have Corinne
sit down so Hudson happy I'm excited
about it anyway we're gonna interview
Corinne later this week Oh shameless
anyway my phone is locked just like
Kristen's anyway so yeah Matt and
Krysten that escalated quickly but
jasmine escalated things even quicker
you knew me and Matt had a thing I said
yeah just even dean was like oh so that
was fast
so
[Music]
hooter on bachelor Winter Games winter
is coming
oh my god I can't I'm just I recently
started watching Game of Thrones from
the very beginning of the whole series
because I felt like I was missing out on
a cultural moment I'm through season two
I haven't been sleeping or working out
very much pretty time-consuming plus for
an hour's a bachelor in paradise every
week I don't have a life anyway so then
we get very Taylor Swift look what you
mean not with Taylor from paradise
but with jasmine calling Kristin snake
devil double mistake look what you mean
me too sneaky Jasmine's like look what
you made me do Kristin yell at you who
so Kristin's all things like I'm in a
rock in a hard place but her and Matt go
in there big date anyway do a banana
stand
did the shut down it did it did it bar
them from booking some good local
restaurants they're literally out of
banana stand
ordering bananas I have Amanda here
ready to find love Robbie and Amanda
Robbie wants to do something romantic
for Amanda so obviously he put some glow
sticks in a hot tub okay he's like we're
gonna get lit but it doesn't get all
that lit cuz amanda says
oh and then Amanda like I mean is just
like honey nice are uncomfortable and
she's like you're hot is then you think
oh maybe she's into it then she needs to
know literally you're physically hot
you're sweating Oh kiss on the neck she
couldn't do it I think that our poor
darling dear Amanda who I love has PTSD
post-traumatic sweaty disorder from Josh
Murray and so when Robbie is sweating in
paradise as men do it flashes her back
and she's can't take it but then they
end up kissing which is really cute and
again I think that their the Kim and
Kanye of paradise and Robbie's all like
I needed to lean in okay Cheryl Sandburg
Robbie Hayes Oh
[Music]
dead crab Adam and Sarah are kind of
talking and like a lot of love triangles
are developing but what I love about
these shows is that people always act
like they're not okay with these love
triangles I don't chuckle very well
you're on a competitive dating based
reality show Adam has to decide Raven or
me babe why are you here but the crazy
moment no one's thought coming Game of
Thrones style was the reality of Dean
you guys you guys drink every time Dean
did something kind of shady this episode
[Music]
Christina and Danielle have both been
talking about or sort of hinting at and
the other girls have to that Dean was
playing both sides juggling Christina
and Danielle but so far Dina's appeared
to be like pretty honest about what he's
doing oh not tonight tonight was
interesting I talked to Danielle about
this on Facebook and you can check that
interview out over on Edie's Facebook
page and she said that huh yeah she
thinks that Dean is the one to be mad at
in the situation out her Christina and
now we see why
she was Dean is like Christina you're
the most fascinating person I've ever
met I mean of course I care a lot about
the way that my actions and affect the
way that you feel and then he's like
Danielle I did not think you would be so
interesting I think I mean I think which
hasn't even really a compliment
please think very similar things to both
of them and Christina's straight up ask
symbol don't you think you're like
dating two people and he's like yes you
do you kiss them both in one night Dean
give me more advice I need the direction
just own it this is the mistake people
make in reality TV they don't own it
they're gonna be on reality TV you can
make mistakes so Dean for Bachelor I
don't know what do you guys think let me
know in the comments was this the kiss
of death was this his head chopped off
and put on a pike was this you know
however I was people dying in a throne
I'm only on season 2
oh and Dean's even like James Connick
I'm not flirting I don't consider it
flirting well I don't consider this
drinking what you need to Derek and
Taylor the golden couple of paradise had
a little bit of a snafu that went from
zero to 180 like really fast but they
worked it out great
moving on Adam and Raven Adam is talking
to Raven and he's like I don't want you
to think about me and Sarah and I'm like
Adam are you auditioning to be on The
Bachelor I don't think it's gonna happen
but who is gonna be the bachelor please
let me know what you guys think because
this episode for me
Phoenix seemed like Wells is a very real
contender because you know Peter Krause
is our frontrunner and I love Peter but
if Peter says no which would pain me and
make me not want to bear any son
any of the kingdoms if Peter says no Nik
vile became the bachelor after being the
funny playful guy making all the
commentary in Paradise what's well doing
me ask him out of the day this gonna
have a zero zero negative consequences
no crazy person came Jasmine's gonna
come and rip my face off he's doing it
with puppets and I'm not really sure why
but I see a lot of parallels parallels
parallels parallels into The Bachelor
seat okay it's getting weird people get
their stuff too chopped off on Game of
Thrones eunuchs look what you made me do
what if executioner said that after you
cut off someone's head
[Music]
he didn't make him do it he was the king
oh my god
I'm ready to go home so Matt because of
all the drama decides to during the
cocktail party before the rose ceremony
leave paradise look what you need him do
he leaves and I think they should have
given Wells a rose to give to somebody
but instead they had someone waiting on
deck
[Music]
wonderful he shows thing you never know
what's gonna happen in game of paradise
oh I don't want any Botox so by the end
of the night Jack stone and Kristen
might be a new couple which I thought
was weird but then after this super
weird conversation realized it makes
total sense they just have been
sociopaths the other stalking sociopaths
and referring to her virginity as a
Czech move like being a virgin has been
a smart move for me that's very Game of
Thrones with Joe prob'ly bit differently
pieces around on your map and see you're
gonna take over next is anyone safe the
tickle monster is coming and it's gonna
be christened torn between the serial
killer and the tickle monster and we
realized we still haven't had a rose
ceremony and that this Dean Kristina
Danielle triangle is still happening you
if that is not dirty dirty game
kristinia dean low they call our deal oh
it's a pair another
okay you guys what did you think is
paradise finally becoming what you
wanted it to be after all the scandal
stuff are you excited for currents big
sit-down do you have questions for
Corinne you can tweet them to me and let
me know my head gear is not as great as
Jasmine's was but make sure to LIKE ET
on Facebook subscribe to us on YouTube
and have a great night everybody
[Music]
what you made me do what you mean you do
what you just made me do though
look what you mean me - what you mean me
- look what you made me do made me do
made me do
Wow I should write theme songs first
shows that no one would watch